meet jack the new intern he works in
technical support troubleshooting
customer issues and he's great at it but
searching for the right file in his
company's massive troubleshooting
catalog takes a lot of time sometimes he
doesn't have time to improve his support
skills and misses out on identifying new
troubleshooting solutions
when a customer emails about a problem
jack begins troubleshooting by searching
through a documentation catalog
documenting new symptoms helps improve
the catalog and a chat bot that gathers
info from the customer might help them
free up more time to do just that
to improve this task jack develops a
chatbot that can reply to customers in
real time providing immediate support
for their basic needs and if the problem
gets complex the bot will create a
ticket so jack can track progress
fueling the bot is a knowledge base this
is where the chatbot finds its answers
jaxbot scrapes troubleshooting documents
to build its knowledge base when the
support department adds new
troubleshooting documents it learns from
them and improves its knowledge base
every time
to build his chatbot jack simply drags
and drops commands into his script the
same way he would build an rpa bot
jack tweaks his chat bot to include a
friendly goodbye message and the chat
bot is complete
finally jack is free to focus on
improving the catalog with new
documentation and improving his skills
by providing higher level assistance to
customers
that's people-powered automation with
ibm rpa and that's what jack calls a
win-win
[Music]